Now that we know Spider-Man is sticking around
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe thanks to
the new deal Sony, Disney, and Marvel reached
in September 2019, it's not totally unreasonable
to think that Spider-Man 3 may feature another
major Avenger.
Well, according to an entirely unconfirmed
rumor published by We Got This Covered, that
idea might become reality.
And by "unconfirmed rumor," we mean "internet
chatter."
And by "might become reality," we mean, "nobody
actually has any idea, but hey we can dream,
right?"
The outlet cites unnamed sources claiming
that the upcoming Spider-Man 3 will co-star
another prominent Avenger: Captain Marvel,
Doctor Strange, or Ms. Marvel whom we've yet
to meet on screen.
Here's what we think.
Let's break this rumor down by starting with
Captain Marvel.
Save for that awesome Endgame scene where
Spidey handed over the Iron Infinity Gauntlet
to the Kree-powered Captain, Peter Parker
and Carol Danvers haven't spent much time
on-screen together.
On the other hand, there is that end-credits
scene from Spider-Man: Far From Home that
featured Talos and Soren, the Skrull couple
who first appeared in Captain Marvel.
If that mysterious scene was setting up some
sort of Skrull storyline for Spider-Man 3,
Captain Marvel will probably want to be involved
in one way or another.
After all, she's basically their savior.
"I'll help you find a home — finish what
Mar-Vell started."
Captain Marvel and Spider-Man are also the
strongest contenders to be the face of the
MCU now that Iron Man and Captain America
are out of the picture, so having them share
the screen in Spider-Man 3 could be Disney's
way of ushering in the new era of Marvel at
the movies.
That said, Tom Holland and Brie Larson are
A-list actors with their own superhero franchises
to focus on so there's a pretty decent chance
that they'll stick to their own corners of
the MCU and never meet up on screen again.
Strange is a Master of the Mystic Arts who
deals with metaphysical threats to our reality.
Spider-Man is a friendly neighborhood hero
whose battles are very grounded.
They're not exactly a perfect superhero match.
That's why it's easy to forget that Spidey
and Strange have a history.
They spent some time together during Avengers:
Infinity War, which saw Peter's idea saving
the Sorcerer Supreme from Ebony Maw and the
duo engaging in a bit of banter though we
can't say that Strange was overly friendly
toward Spidey.
"Wh-what is he, your ward?"
"No.
I'm Peter, by the way."
"Doctor Strange."
"Oh, you're using your made-up names…
Um, I'm Spider-Man, then."
Strange is also based in New York, like Spidey,
so the odds of the two of them bumping into
one another seems fairly high.
On the flip side, though, the upcoming Doctor
Strange in the Multiverse of Madness is bringing
another Avenger into the Sorcerer Supreme's
world for a little crossover action: Elizabeth
Olsen's Scarlet Witch.
The flick is set to launch in theaters on
May 7, 2021 just a few months before Spider-Man
3 opens on July 16, 2021.
After watching Strange and Scarlet team up
in Doctor Strange in the Multiverse of Madness,
audiences may have a "been there, done that"
attitude to Spider-Man 3 if it truly does
feature Doctor Strange.
If the name "Ms. Marvel" isn't ringing any
bells for you, that's because the character
hasn't yet appeared on screen — but she
will.
Kamala Khan, the Pakistani
American teenager who can stretch and bend
her body into all sorts of shapes, is confirmed
to star on her own upcoming series on the
new streaming service Disney+ a few years
from now.
If Ms. Marvel doesn't premiere until 2022,
the character could first appear in Spider-Man
3.
On one hand, Ms. Marvel debuting in Spider-Man
3 might make sense.
Kamala is around the same age as Peter, and
since the MCU has no other teen heroes, it
would be great to see the two share the screen
together.
On the other hand, it might be a horrible
decision.
The House of Heroes rarely makes mistakes
when it comes to introducing characters into
its mammoth franchise that spans film and
now television, and having Kamala Khan take
her first turn on the screen in someone else's
movie could be a massive misstep that robs
the young hero of her own proper debut.
Regardless of whether any of these Avengers
or any Avengers at all will join Peter Parker
in Spider-Man 3, Disney and Marvel clearly
don't plan on losing Spider-Man anytime soon.
Spider-Man 3 could be one big Avengers reunion,
or it could be strictly centered around Spidey
himself.
Either way, the film is sure to be a smash
when it swings into theaters on July 16, 2021.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.